we start with our Bloomberg exclusive
this morning the governor of the Central
Bank of Russia has told this channel
that Russia will not inflate its way out
of the financial crisis it is faced in
her first ever interview with an
international broadcaster Elvira
Nabiullina told Bloomberg's Rhine
Chilcote the bank is unlikely to
reversed last month's surprise rate cut
as inflation is there to slow having
accelerated to the fastest in almost
seven years and Ryan is here with us now
fascinating conversation then yeah you
know we started with the ruble I asked
if you know what was one of the world's
most the worst performing currencies
last year if we can expect more
collapses there's talk of course of that
and she said no have a listen
conditionally Coco vertical much w-was
using a coaster
we of course not expecting any kind of
massive decrease in the rubles exchange
rate because the decline in the oil
price we saw was the third biggest in
the last 40 years and the amount of
external debt that has to be paid this
year is about a third less than last
year she reported I'll go for cheaper
route stangard year on your inflation
could it go beyond 20 percent did not
separate center inflation may be higher
than the current 15 percent but these
higher levels of inflation are driven by
past factors moreover I'd like to point
out that other inflationary factors will
subside it's only factor we expect a
contraction in economic activity and of
course a contraction in demand on top of
that we have very moderate dynamics in
the money supply that's why we really
expect inflation to slow down in the
second quarter after the second quarter
in the second half of the year and into
2016 that's why there is no reason to
talk about the inevitability of a rate
increase when do you see lowering rates
pretty much in a post outcome
we'll make the decision on rates based
on our analysis of the situation in the
economy our forecasts on the economy's
development and above all on the
dynamics of inflation analyzing the
entire balance of risks inflationary
risks to growth and to financial
stability we'll make a decision that is
consistent with our task of reducing
inflation within the framework of our
inflation targeting and achieving a
level of 4% in the midterm we all see
the Syrian huge field of Preventive
service which the perspective when you
lower grades from 17% 15% you surprised
almost everybody and the conversation
began how independent really is Russia's
central bank are you independent or is
this an arm of the Kremlin when we made
the decision on cutting rates we didn't
do it at the expense of inflation now
Walter the expense of our task in
reducing inflation we based it on our
forecasts for inflation and for economic
growth of course there is a lot of
cynicism of the central bank but the
Bank of Russia is very used to criticism
the right interest groups in the economy
some gain from a weak ruble fat is
gained from a strong ruble for many
years the central bank has been
criticized on all sides so we're used to
it are you independent we are
independent there you have it she says
she's independent look she has one of
the toughest jobs in the world already
the seventh largest economy she's
sitting on you know close to half a
trillion dollars worth of assets
Russia's headed into a recession the
currency last year was one of the
world's worst performing now it's the
world's most volatile so I think a
couple things to think about here first
off on rates elder at nebula net last
year nearly tripled rates started the
year at five and a half percent the key
rate went all the way up to 17 and then
the issue was just a short while ago in
January she cut it to 15 surprising
absolutely everyone there was no
suggestion that she was going to do that
that's what prompted the whole
conversation is you heard there about
whether she's really independent
but as you heard her her argument is
it's not about where inflation is right
now it's where inflation is going sure
it's gonna pick up in the first half of
the year she conceded that beyond 15
percent which is pretty extraordinary if
you think about it but in the second
half of the year she says he's going to
fall but all the while you know she
invokes Paul Volcker at one point is one
of you know the kind of central bankers
that she likes and respects she paints
herself as someone who first and
foremost is thinking about inflation and
fighting inflation and someone who will
not allow Russia to inflate itself out
of the crisis of course in the context
of other central banks cutting rates it
wasn't that much of a shock in its own
right it was but versus everyone else
it's cut rates this year it wasn't just
a little bit added to that yeah it's a
big week in the Ukraine conflict
diplomacy is escalating leaders head to
mints Russia France Germany on Wednesday
and Merkel heads to Washington is there
a growing position between the US and
Germany well you know we don't know and
basically John Kerry was asked about
that over the weekend and his point was
that while we have differences with the
United State the European Union and the
main difference is whether it's even
worth talking about arming the Ukrainian
military those differences as he put it
our tactical they're not strategic but
what's interesting is we've got this big
pickup in diplomacy right you've got the
four leaders actually gathering see if
it happens on Wednesday in the capital
of Belarus in Minsk Paresh Anka Putin
Merkel Oland for peace talks
I don't think trying to remember if the
configuration those four haven't met
since d-day in Normandy it's been a very
long time we've had lots of talks but
never at that kind of senior level never
we had the you know the Russian
president the Ukrainian president
sitting down with two intermediaries
like that so this could be really big
and why it's because you know there's as
Merkel put it last week there's no
particular reason to believe
right now that there's any more read the
sir chance of solving this crisis than
there was last week they just believe
that this is an opportunity an effort
that has to be seized upon before it's
too late so we'll see where that goes
but you know the issue of arming the
Ukrainian military is out there and the
issue of imposing more sanctions against
Russia perhaps as a compromise between
the United States the European Union is
also